le bout du tunnel s'entrevoit outre
manche alors que les terrasses des
restaurants étaient déjà rouvert depuis
avril le service en salle a lui aussi
repris ce lundi un retour très important
pour les restaurateurs mais aussi un
grand bol d'air pour les clients qui
retrouvent un peu de normalité dans leur
quotidien
c'est bizarre c'est fait du bien tu ne
peux pas mentir ça faisait vraiment trop
longtemps mais c'est un peu bizarre
parce que nous marchions dans la rue
pour venir et tout est ouvert
ça n'a pas été comme ça depuis longtemps
ça fait vraiment du bien oui jacques
chan c'est comme une sorte de sentiment
d'être à l'aise si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire les choses reviennent à la
normale
une sorte de normalité est en train de
revenir le crâne comment pas parmi les
restrictions levées figure aussi la
possibilité de se rendre au stade mais
aussi au musée au théâtre ou encore au
cinéma
l'occasion pour les cinéphiles de
retourner en salle avec un peu de pop
corn et une boisson
l'industrie du cinéma quant à elle va
pouvoir relever la tête après une
période compliquée c'est assez génial
parce que je n'ai pas vu de films au
cinéma depuis le début de la pandémie
donc c'est une expérience assez unique
maintenant que celle-ci se termine cela
paraît surréaliste de retourner au
cinéma mais c'est super excitant parce
qu'on a envie de pouvoir regarder des
films à nouveau et titre il est
difficile d'être précis nous vivons une
période sans précédent mais la demande
est fantastique
nous avons peter rabbit 2 qui est
probablement le plus grand film du
moment et les pré réservations pour ce
film sont 50% plus élevé que pour la
première version et le déconfinement
totale du pays est prévue pour le 21
juin prochain
cependant cette date pourrait être
rediscuté en fonction de l'évolution du
variant indien
le nombre de cas d'infection à celui ci
a d'oublier à londres la semaine
dernière le premier ministre britannique
boris johnson a appelé la population à
profiter de ces libertés avec une grande
dose de précaution il a aussi indiqué
que la propagation du variant étaient
sous étroite surveillance